trevor reed's family is preparing for
his return at the home in texas
his father joey hanging an american flag
his mother paula struggling to contain
her joy finally after waiting all this
time i'm going to be able to hug my kid
you know put my arms around him you know
i had a little bit of a
panic attack when he told me he was
going to spend the whole summer in
russia so nine months and then now it's
been almost a thousand days so i'm just
excited to see him
the former marine was sentenced to a
nine-year sentence in july 2020
he was accused and convicted of
drunkenly assaulting russian police
officers
though he insisted during his trial he
had no memory of the event his family
described the charges as deeply
suspicious and last month held a protest
at the white house before meeting with
president biden to ask him to help
secure their son's release
in a statement president biden has
praised the safe return of reed as a
testament to the priority his
administration places on bringing home
americans held hostage and wrongfully
detained abroad
adding it required difficult decisions
that i do not take lightly when he
referenced uh the tough decision in his
uh statement this morning he was
referencing uh the decision to commute
the sentence of constantino
uh i would emphasize that
this individual had already served the
majority of his prison sentence for
non-violent drug crime the press
secretary would not be drawn on the fate
of other americans being held in russia
has the president been in touch with her
busy plan to reach out to paul whelan's
family brittany greiner's family any
other families who have loved west
detained in russia
we have of course been in touch with
their families over the course of time
i'm not going to detail those
conversations further after being
released from prison reid was
transferred from a russian plane to a
u.s one at a turkish airport the primary
concern of his waiting family is his
health as his parents we know he does
not look well he's very thin he was
walking strange and it looked like they
had to help him get up in the airplane
yeah he didn't look good so i understand
there's some medical personnel on the
plane with him and they're checking him
out so that's our main concern right now
and the debriefing and all that stuff
that can come later we just want to make
sure that his health is good
but the parents have returned into their
home
content that their son is free
the prisoner swap would have been
remarkable even in times of peace
but it's all the more surprising given
that russia's invasion of ukraine
has driven the relationship with the us
to the lowest level this century
mike hanna al jazeera washington